PFT and big-cat of course they host
pardon my take the biggest sports
podcast in the world
it's the biggest sports podcast in the
world is that we say it so you say
something with confidence people believe
everyday is amazing right like you just
sell it and they buy it wrong yes I mean
like my wife is like talking to her dad
she's like you know there's a number to
show on Sirius XM salmon and Jim and Sam
and and her dad was like oh did you guys
get the numbers and I'm like I was
really kind of banking on nofollow'
number two is exactly perfect you
because nobody's gonna dig too deep on
that right number one you get all sorts
of follow up I've got a challenge from
the number one but no one number two
because you can't prove it anybody else
here being like no we're number two like
nobody wants to fight over that that's a
bad hole yeah you're saying the biggest
sports put you in India [ __ ] bill
Simmons your other guys know what you
are which we don't know they just know
they just came out like literally 30
minutes ago okay the 2018 rankings came
out and we're you beat the [ __ ] out of
Bill one of those things that we you
know what kind of started as a joke and
and it keeps growing and it's like is
this never gonna we actually had this
conversation like is it gonna stop at
some point we're gonna Plateau and it
just hasn't happened yet so you're just
never gonna pop you never gonna reach
that pinnacle so when you guys start
doing really well when part of my take
like kind of takes off do you start to
go oh [ __ ] do we have a responsibility
to actually talk about sports here like
our people are people coming here for
something now or do we just keep goofing
on well I think there's it we do the
thing is we are like diehard sports fans
so we do love talking about sports but
at the end of the day it's a comedy show
and we're trying to make people laugh
and so we'll every now and then we'll
get I think I had someone this morning
being like I'm just always I loved your
show but I'm always bummed out that you
bash on Urban Meyer and it's like well
of course we're gonna bash on Urban
Meyer he fakes that he's got a heart
attack every time the
Ohio State loses a game no but I think
it's just that blend of you know a
little bit of real a lot of fun trying
to interview someone get some real
information out of them try to bust
their balls and have some fun with it is
it amazing how mad people get his
[ __ ] sports stuff - yep [ __ ]
bastard they don't like who they like or
you don't like different this week is
like the perfect example of that -
because the college football rankings
come out and no matter what you're gonna
have three fan bases that hate you
right and so this year it was you know
Ohio State Georgia
maybe a little UCF getting in there -
like there was an argument to be made
for a lot of different teams and so it's
it's fun to poke that hornet's nest and
everybody seems to enjoy it until it's
like their team and then there's certain
fan bases like Ohio State's won the
Steelers believe it or not like if you
make fun of the Steelers they will
[ __ ] go out yeah any place that's
[ __ ] still like a steel or mining
town those people keep coming back as
their diehard sports fans - so you make
fun of their team they'll get maybe a
little angry for a second but then we're
moving on to the next team and they'll
have fun with that so you get that like
every week there's always somebody
that's going you know usually you guys
are pretty funny but you were way off
this stupid yeah usually whenever you
make fun of whoever's favorite core your
favorite quarterback is or you know and
the thing is we are we are very very
open about our bias so you know we've we
have Blake bortles as a friend of ours
and he got benched and we just won't
talk about it on the show
that was a big mistake even though he's
had a terrible season for no reason yeah
we're very open when we're telling you
like yo we only like this guy cuz he's
our friend nothing to do with his talent
right have there been guys that you'll
tease on the show and then become
friends with and then now we don't make
fun of him anymore because now he's our
friend Joe Buck is probably a good
example also like we start everybody
kind of hated Joe Buck a couple years
ago scores we went in on him he came on
our show and he was he was awesome he's
just like genuinely a good person and so
he's been back on like five times since
that are so yeah it's inviting that's
that's what started annoying me but now
we got to go to like the other side of
Joe Buck because everybody loves Joe now
yeah the last couple years he's like
rehabilitate his image
so now we have to start being a little
bit mean to him again [ __ ] on somebody
and then when you talk to me like [ __ ] I
like this guy's [ __ ] I don't know how
big college basketball fans you guys are
assuming not at all
yeah yeah but I'm Korean who was the
coach in Indiana now coach to Georgia we
used to [ __ ] on him all the time and
then we met him he we were we'd take a
tour every single May where we get in a
van and we just drive and trying to
interview people he had just been fired
from Indiana and we hit him up and we're
like hey we're gonna be in Indiana
can you come come to our show he showed
up we were in a party city parking lot
in a sketchy van sat with us for an hour
and a half were like damn we like this
guy has there been anybody you guys
wanted to talk to you like art this guy
will be gray he'll be a fun and they
just give you somebody's athletes our
[ __ ] touch and go yeah they don't
want to talk they [ __ ] just sit there
you know what it is is you guys probably
deal with it all the time you can tell
almost instantly when someone when
you're doing an interview with someone
and they're just there to plug something
and it's just like talk about the same
so we had an interview with dak Prescott
who's the quarterback of the Cowboys and
at the end of the interview on a hot mic
he the PR person was like how'd that go
and he just goes miserable this awful
interview is worth playing because we
have that soundbite yeah these guys come
over show and they think they're going
on you know like just any other sports
show and they come on the first question
we ask him is like hey how come you're
named after a porn star because his name
is Dakota rain and he was like what at
the end he goes it was miserable they
asked me about porn maybe you're wrong
guys were [ __ ] about beating their
wives and you're worried about [ __ ]
Freddy
your boss is Jerry Jones your boss is
banging strippers and prostitutes during
games probably but most people
understand that if they come on and they
at least just have fun like you don't
even have to answer that question yeah
question you just have to laugh and yeah
he's a cool guy
we had Karima on one time he was
terrible he was pushing a book about
like black culture or black heroes and
it was all right fine we're talking
basketball with him I don't know he's
the [ __ ] highest scorer in NBA
history and his publicist who's a
delight yes was a bit miffed that we
were not talking about the book and it's
like the but we'll get to the book we
like the book Oh lovely home every
person that has ever interviewed Kareem
that's the first thing that you talk
about yeah
asked for what he asked for like an iced
tea and and one of our guys just handed
him an iced tea and she screamed she's
like no no put it in a glass put it
we're like what though what's going on
right yeah she don't aureus I am very
interested as to what their relationship
is it may just be and I jokingly guessed
it might be something different than
what it is but I could be wrong
yes Jim started going into sub Dom
potential relationship it wouldn't
surprise me but I can I've shown them in
the airport together and I mean it's
probably just a publicist relationship
possible that he's getting pegged it's
always possible it's all I hope for it
every time I meet someone like the sex
swing that would have to be designed
first I saw Ellie action we were on a
flight he was like three seats behind me
so he sits on the [ __ ] plane and he
puts the blanket over his head because
he wants to just like block out the
light nice so everyone's he's the most
recognizable guy in Los Angeles
everybody's sitting there with just a
blanket over his face trying to be left
alone in this seat on a full version of
Michael Myers as a ghost yeah like you
just thank God I'm short that's why I am
NOT tall because I was actually smarty
yeah the you do wrestling stuff oh yeah
yeah you do I've seen you do stuff with
Pat McAfee who used to work with right I
want to ask me for the because it was a
college football playoffs it was another
way to doing Mount Rushmore the top four
finishing moves in wrestling history oh
my god
well tombstone piledrivers yeah Stone
Cold Stunner is on there I proudly put
the figure-four on their dream elevator
and Greg Valentine and sharpshooter and
I think Sweet Chin Music I don't know if
I could put how about the leg drop Oh
I mean look Hogan made it look great
right but I don't know how effective
Plescia spine problems that stem from it
like it really wasn't that great of a
move to do yeah sharp shooters a really
good one I'd probably put sharpshooter
in there before yes sweet chains I like
the bronco buster
yeah he just put his dick in your face
really quit you know did you ever see
the footage of him tearing his [ __ ]
doing the [ __ ] Bronco but remember that
I'm not but I would like to so he tore
his [ __ ] doing this Bronco buster
like an indie show and he didn't know
how bad it was because he was wearing
like rubber tights and so everything was
packed in and so he kept doing the match
and he went through a table and he did
all this stuff and then he went to the
after-party still in his tights not
knowing because it was all you know
everything was cinched in and then he
gets back to the hotel room and he said
he almost bled out oh because he took
his tights down and everything from his
[ __ ] just pours out you know it's
tough to be bleeding [ __ ] and not
notice at the after-party
he's XY he's the [ __ ] Mex bakken cane
yeah I mean it was just so weird and
that's why you're not familiar with the
corner he hit the match he finishes the
[Music]
my [ __ ] would just go please that's
what residues like that's not the finish
so I'm kicking out yeah I my ass was
torn but I'm not losing
I just glad the expose to a bar wearing
those tights afterwards people there -
yeah he's in he's in like way better
shape now this is what he was in his
like kind of dark days like right around
the time you would think you'd tear your
ass probably told the other guy look
there's a problem so the other guy's
just laying there and it's like pounding
the Eternity man in pain because his
[ __ ] hurts so what happens if you
Terry [ __ ] do you get stitches yeah
yeah and I think
got to walk around on lake with one of
those you know inner-tube things to sit
on and everything yeah yeah I imagine
you get the the likelihood of an
infection with the tornado it's probably
pretty high yeah huge and then we found
out after this he tore his [ __ ] his
[ __ ] got fixed and then he broke his
dick [ __ ] a girl oh so just
everything on a surface yeah you guys
were you ultimately happy that ESPN went
the way ESPN went because I feel like it
made you a dangerous notorious podcast
that you only lasted one day on ESPN
yeah yeah I mean it's definitely I think
there's like looking back on in the
moment it sucked like you don't want to
obviously if you guys were gonna be like
ESPN was going in this other direction
you guys are gonna be the faces yeah we
were you know it was it was one of those
situations to where they wanted to take
the risk but they didn't want to put in
the money so we had a full show on an
absolutely ridiculous budget like I
sometimes I've talked to people they're
like oh you didn't have writers like no
what I couldn't afford writers the whole
thing so we're gonna kill ourselves
doing the show so when I got cancelled
it sucked but it also you like you said
the the bad-boy image intact yeah they
were kind of like keeping us at arm's
length to begin with I mean yes there
was like a lot of buzz around it but at
the end of the day it was a 1:00 a.m.
show on espn2 it's not like they were
they were putting us like front and
center yeah at the time it was awful in
retrospect it was like yeah that's a
funny story like I don't care how you
slice it it sucked at the time but the
fact that we we worked hard we got on
the ESPN finally and then it lasted
about two days like that that's a funny
story so like we can look back and laugh
on it now and yeah I gave us like a
little bit of street cred or whatever
but yeah I think in retrospect probably
worked out well for both sides ESPN's
probably happy it made them look stupid
doing it also gave us and I hate to say
this out loud but whenever someone
thinks they're like dunking on us
they're like oh you had one should your
show got canceled on ESPN and I just
like I don't really care it's almost
like a free like they think they get me
but I'm just like I really don't give a
[ __ ] I cancelled after one episode you
can't be so bad that there has to be
something else right right right good
point five episodes maybe like well that
shows so if you had nine
episodes ever twelve people like like
like what if what happened yeah Hardaway
or grant hey Len Bias
the greatest show ever probably sucked
we could have could have been the
greatest ever I mean you're kicking Bill
Simmons ass and podcasting you could
have more attractive than I am though so
TV might be a better medium for high
maybe you're right yeah were you guys
bummed that the McAfee left barstool
yeah I mean that was a friend and I
actually Pat coming to barstool he I
tell the story but he DM me on Twitter
and was like hey can you watch my
stand-up set and he sent me a DVD of it
in 2013 I was like who the [ __ ] sends
DVDs to bro you could have just sent me
like a Dropbox linker on YouTube so like
we were friends and you know it didn't
work out but I think we're still friends
I don't know I haven't talked to him
well uh barstool radio has finally
gotten you guys over like you guys have
been one of the biggest if not the
biggest podcast on that barstool network
but you weren't on the Sirius XM channel
I was PFT just added his show right oh
yeah how come you're not doing part of
my take as a serious show just because
you want to keep the podcast brand as it
is yeah I think people like it first
thing in the morning and if you know
we're able to record it like late at
night so they got it there when it comes
out the next day and I think it's more
valuable actually to the company yeah on
like via podcast selling ads against it
what time do you guys think we depends
on you on the day but if it's like
Thursday night or Sunday night when
there's football we get out at about
like 2:00 a.m.
1:38 was it like an hour show two hours
yeah about an hour okay
yeah so and it wouldn't you know doing
it every day would kind of burn us out
as well yeah week three times a week
isn't it great anything like I love we
go to LA and tape late at night you were
so used to be anything better than tape
being nice dude [ __ ] do it when I did
it right into the solo show from 9:00
p.m. to midnight he's great he's just
nobody's around to bother you you do
whatever you want the fans are it's my
mom works better at night I'm a stand-up
so I think the exact same way whatever I
mean this doing this right now you used
to just call right I have to be funny or
whatever under these circumstances the
mornings are never ideal